Democrats continue their downward spiral
as pollsters up Republican chances for
the midterms all of which exposes a
fundamental rule of politics when your
opponent gets angry your opponent gets
stupid then CNN and Twitter exposed
themselves as hypocrites
president Trump offers voters an honest
choice and Teen Vogue gives us the
dumbest article on the Internet today
all that and more I'm Michael Nolan this
is the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
things are going from bad to worse for
Senate Democrats some other candidates
as well looking really bad Nate Silver
the you know he's the pollster who made
his career just predicting that Obama
would win things Nate silver a
left-leaning pollster is saying that
right now there's a better chance that
the GOP picks up votes in the Senate
then that the Democrats take the Senate
people are losing their minds in these
rate Heidi Heitkamp
beta O'Rourke you know the Mexican beta
O'Rourke Malladi
Oh better Boy the pipes the pipes are
calling will cover all of those races
first I've got to make a little money
honey and I've got to tell you about
purple mattress listen I've told you
about purple mattress but I think last
week week before so I had just gotten it
I've now had my purple mattress for like
two or three weeks this is the greatest
mattress ever invented I was a little
skeptical I'm gonna be very honest I'd
always use the springy mattresses you
know the inner spring and I tried some
the memory foam and they were they were
fine whatever
purple mattress is something completely
different so I tried it out you know got
the California King saving my marriage
it is phenomenal they use this material
there's there are different kinds of
foam and it's really heavy too I mean
this is a very heavy mattress because
they use the best materials available
this is not some flimsy thing but then
there's this material that they've
invented it was developed by a rocket
scientist it's kind of like a jelly I I
don't I don't know how to describe it it
is the best I've nests had this mattress
for what two or three weeks I feel way
better my back feels better I've got
more energy you know I need like
eighteen or nineteen hours of sleep a
day this thing is phenomenal it will
feel unlike anything you've ever
experienced in a bed it feels I when I
was reading this I didn't really believe
it it feels both firm and soft at the
same time I know that sounds like a
contradiction it does it totally works
it is great like I am a believer I'm a
proselytizer of this thing now I keeps
everything supported you'll feel really
comfortable you get a hundred night
risk-free trial if you're not fully
satisfied you can return the mattress
for a full refund backed up by a 10-year
warranty free shipping and returns
you're not gonna want to return it it's
just phenomenal your
love purple right now my listeners get a
free purple pillow with the purchase of
a mattress I know I have to buy a purple
pillow because I'm so into the mattress
that I want the matching pillow that's
an addition to all the great free gifts
they give you site-wide Cove just text
this is how you get it here's how you
get your deal text Kofi a CoV Fe Fe - 47
47 47 that is the only way to get this
free pillow text cough FA CE o of the fe
Fe - 47 47 47 do it right now I'm
telling you do it right now one because
it's funny to text Co 5 a 2 because you
should get more information on this
mattress
Coface CoV Fe Fe - 47 47 47 you will
thank me later
okay so nate silver's putting GOP
chances at picking up seats in the
Senate picking up seats at a higher
chance than Democrats taking the Senate
right now the Senate is very close and
who knows anything could happen in the
midterms the party that holds the White
House is supposed to lose seats maybe
lose the Congress lose the Senate things
are looking pretty good to drive this
point home things are looking so good
right now
for Republicans compared to what they
should be looking like that there's this
candidate in in Nevada GOP candidate for
state legislature who is a pimp he owns
a bunch of brothels he died a few days
ago a dead pimp discovered it as brothel
by ron jeremy the 70s porn star after a
party that was attended by joe arpaio
the sheriff Grover Norquist the tax guy
and Tucker Carlson called in dead the
guy is actually dead dead pimp in Nevada
he is poised to win his race it is right
now all of the polling suggests a dead
pimp in Nevada is gonna win the race
because he's a Republican over the
Democrat this is unbelievable stuff now
look anything that could happen here I
don't want you to be confused with my
making a prediction predictions can
become self-fulfilling here if the
Republicans don't feel motivated they
won't get out the vote and they're gonna
lose everything they're going to lose
everything and then they're gonna whip
each Trump and then they're gonna try to
convict Trump in the Senate an eight
silver the left wing pollster still puts
Democrats at an eighty four percent
chance of taking the house
that's what the data say right now data
have been wrong before I've got four
hundred smackers in a check signed by
Ben Shapiro over there because the data
were wrong in 2016
anything could happen right now
enthusiasm is really high on the
Republican side this is some something
of what is unprecedented in part it's
because of Cavanaugh in part it's
because of Lyle waffle is warned in part
it's because of these unfair the Russia
investigation that's I think now and its
75th year it's good you know all of
these things seemed very unfair the news
media stacked against them and that
everything is going so well in the
country which we'll cover a little bit
later but you know the economy is going
well unemployment basically doesn't
exist things are going gangbusters Alan
Greenspan the former Federal Reserve
Chairman says that this is the tightest
labor market he's ever seen in his life
and Alan Greenspan is like 7,000 years
old so things are going really well
that's why Republican enthusiasm is up
Democrat enthusiasm is really high too
so let's say Republicans have enthusiasm
at 2010 levels Democrat enthusiasm is
really high which means it's anybody's
game it's all about getting Republicans
out there and and depressing the
Democrat vote which the mainstream media
and Democrats themselves have done
pretty pretty well I wonder I think
there's a chance that maybe only one out
of 1,024 Democrats will actually show up
you know we'll only get one 1020 forth
of the Democrat expected vote but
they've really gone mad so this gets to
my central thesis here which is that
when your opponent gets angry your
opponent behaved stupidly get angry go
mad get stupid and Donald Trump has made
them angry he's driven them mad and
therefore they've gotten a little bit
stupid to just give you a little taste
of this I will show you a glimpse of
every Democrat voter in the country
that that about sums it up that's pretty
much every voter ripping up the sign you
know getting all crazy this was a guy
who was just walking down the street
trying to tear up Ted Cruz signs
obviously the Democrats have been driven
mad they they have a madness they have
gone crazy that guy looks like a demon
he's BM what what have you to do with us
Ted Cruz our hour is not yet come ah
whatever you know you're ours now yucca
we mentioned this last week voxcom the
left-wing outlet has been encouraging
democrats to practice witchcraft it's
not a joke you know pat robertson said
this in 92
he said that feminism makes people
practice witchcraft now voxcom is
proving him right they're saying yeah
democrats should practice witchcraft in
solidarity with one another
there was a story out today that a woman
has become an abortion doula in New York
you know a doula
to help a woman through pregnancy she's
become the opposite of that she's become
an abortion doula and she's asked and
begged to be in the room for 2,000
abortions and the woman looks like a
witch she's got crazy colored hair she
looks all kooky she looks like you I
mean if you just look up witch in the
dictionary you'll get this woman also
speaking of witches and demons these
antifa the quote-unquote anti-fascists
in Brooklyn from catland books are now
calling themselves witches and they're
saying that they're going to put a hex
on Brett Kavanaugh they're going to use
a bunch of spells and magic and things
like that to put a hex on our new
Supreme Court justice Brett Kavanaugh
and when they were asked about this why
is aunt Eva the this left-wing political
group why are they associating with
witchcraft they said this quote we are
embracing witchcrafts true roots as the
magic of the poor the downtrodden and
disenfranchised and its history as often
the only weapon the only means of
exacting justice available to those of
us who have been wronged by men now that
luckily we've got priests and exorcists
praying for Brett Kavanaugh so hopefully
the hex won't work and the empty feh
lunatic witches will be a stymied but
reminds me of a central book on the left
rules for radicals by Saul Alinsky so
olenski tactics used by Barack Obama a
friend of Hillary Clinton's Hillary
Clinton wrote her senior thesis on Saul
Alinsky they had a lot of correspondence
back and forth she called him a mentor
and a friend of hers and Saul Alinsky
dedicated his most famous book rules for
radicals to Lucifer to that first rebel
who won himself a kingdom Lucifer he
dedicated after the first edition I
think they took that dedication out but
it's in the first edition and it really
does make me wonder look at the imagery
on both sides you've got broadly across
the left people adopting witchcraft
imagery cultish imagery satanic imagery
evil wicked dark imagery and then you
know obviously on the right there's a
the religious right that adopts a light
imagery godly imagery I don't think
that's an accident I really don't think
that's an accident and just listen to
how those witches in Brooklyn and how
Saul Alinsky you know the the community
organizer thug who was a an ideological
hustler especially exploiting poor
people they they put these witchcraft
images into ideological leftist terms
they say witchcraft is about the poor
over the rich or about the oppressed
over the oppressors or this or that
they're using all of that divisive
language of the left making about us
versus them we're gonna start a new
world us but we're gonna conquer them
it's all about division it's all about
greed and ultimately it's all about
failure I really don't think it's a
coincidence you know and that this is a
step along the road you make your
opponents angry you make them mad you
make them lose their minds you make them
look like that guy with the Cruz signs
I hate Ted Cruz bad not bad not bad I
was oh I'm sorry by the way that almost
lapsed into a sweet little ELISA voice I
didn't mean to do that that was a demon
voice that I I was intending this is the
rule you make your opponents angry you
make them mad and you get them to act
stupidly this is the great advantage we
have going into these midterms heidi
heitkamp we talked about this yesterday
running in in North Dakota she is
Democrat she's down by a lot she was
already down by about 12 points and
she released a newspaper ad listing
purported victims of sexual assault the
only problem was they never consented to
have their names in the newspaper ad
some of them don't support Heidi
Heitkamp some of them say they weren't
even sexually assaulted I mean this is a
total catastrophe for hike camp a total
meltdown she came out and she apologized
but I mean this is probably gonna kill
her campaign the fallout is still
happening here is one of the women who
was named in that advertisement giving
giving her opinion of Heidi Heitkamp
tactic we just heard from Senator
Heitkamp who said all I can do is say
I'm sorry I want to know what I can do
to fix this has she said that personally
to you that she's sorry um no she has
not you were told though as I understand
it that she would be reaching out uh yep
I was told that she was gonna reach out
to every one of the women that was um
you know put in this without our consent
but she has yet to reach out to me she
said she also wants to know what she can
do to fix this is there something in
your mind we could do uh you know the
damage has kind of already been done you
know the names that didn't want to be
put out they're already out there for
the world to see and you can't really
retract that the damage is done
the damage is already done you there are
certain things you can't undo there are
certain things you can't unsay you know
in politics slick politicians are always
trying to leave themselves wiggle room
always leave yourself an exit strategy
whatever you say whatever promise you
make whatever tactic you employ and
usually good politicians are very
careful about all of these things but
when you start to really get emotional
when you start to get really passionate
when you start to get really angry you
start to make mistakes and that's what
Heidi Heitkamp did here she was so
whipped up into a frenzy by the me2
movement by the Kavanaugh stuff by
Donald Trump talking about women that
she allowed herself to make a colossal
mistake you can't you can't take that
back and so it doesn't look like she's
got a real future this is another point
I want to underscore we talked about
this when nikki Haley gave that speech
about how we shouldn't own the libs how
it's a bad idea to own the libs and to
get people angry and to get to trigger
them and to make
of them because it doesn't persuade
anybody nonsense this is why you have to
own the lips this is why because you
whip your opponents into an anger and
into a frenzy and then they make
mistakes they hang themselves they tie
the rope and they throw it over the beam
you know I mean they were really will do
they will do the work for you it's not
that Donald Trump is some master
tactician and strategist I don't think
he is at all
I think he's extraordinarily effective
because he triggers his opponents into
doing all the damage themselves and
that's that's what's happened with this
hype camp thing here is here are some I
mean the fallout even on CNN even on
these left-wing outlets even on the the
mainstream news ABC NBC even they have
to admit that this was a big error
listen to what some of the other victims
are saying she says she's terrified for
her safety like many other victims
because of this situation that's right
it's actually putting these girls in
danger the reason that voice was all
messed up is because she's trying to
hide her identity and hide her voice so
they put a little scrambler on her but
of course it's tantamount to daxing
people in the age of social media in the
age where you can look up someone's name
and find out basically where they are
this is tantamount to daxing there were
people who were trying to Doc's
United States senators in in the US
Congress and those people were real I
mean that that is felonious behavior and
but they're doing it because they were
whipped into such a frenzy they couldn't
see the consequences of their actions
this was such an obvious blunder just
someone who is thinking clearly but
you've always got to think clearly I
think this is also true for the people
on the right you know some people on the
right were really triggered by President
Trump as both this president and as a
candidate and they started thinking
emotionally a little bit too and some of
them have egg on their face now you
don't want to do that you should always
view politics clearly politics lives on
outrage of thrives on outrage we'll
explain why Donald Trump knows this and
he's using it too are all of our
in a little bit but you you at least
have to try to think clearly you know
what I have this rule on Twitter if I
ever sinned or to get angry which is
almost never happens if I ever start to
feel that way I log off Twitter I don't
I cuz then you make mistakes you don't
want to leave yourself open to making
those kinds of mistakes by the way the
mainstream media mob word carefully
selected the mainstream media mob or
letting themselves make mistakes too
because they are really starting to lose
it as well here is just a clip from I
think her name was Brooke Baldwin she so
you know this this whole mob issue she
said this girl on her show Brooke
Baldwin said I'm not gonna let people
use that talking point I'm not gonna let
them use the word mine she cut off this
guy cuz he said Democrats are behaving
like a mob you know there's mob violence
Democrats are calling for more mob
violence at politicians homes she I'm
not gonna let you use that talking point
here's her defending her line so we had
Matt Lewis on who I love having on from
The Daily Beast and he brought up the
word mob and at the time the mob the mob
word had been this talking point from
Republicans from all up and down Capitol
Hill in the wake of what had happened
with with dr. Ford and justice Cavanaugh
and so when he brought the mob word up
again I I called him I called him out
and listen like I don't want to be the
word police and that was not my
intention but I also believe in calling
out talking points and to hear him bring
that up I had to I had to say something
I don't want to be the word police but
she say you know and they say but it
means the opposite of what I just said
that's always oh well I don't I support
free speech but and so she's okay but
fair enough she says I think those
talking points they're shallow they're
cheap and I'm not gonna let people get
away with talking points on my show
ain't gonna happen
right hold on let's cut back a few weeks
or a few months are you sure about that
per Bolton
she made a determination with her doctor
that she would power through this she
made a decision to just power through
this we've decided to power through
sometimes just power through this
continue to power through what yes she
tried to power through it she decided to
power through it well you know for
she just wanted to power through she
just wanted to power through her
schedule so she wanted to just power
through and keep doing it I appreciate
all of their desire to power through
power through and get things done if she
tried to power through it it was Hillary
Clinton's decision essentially to power
through yeah Brooke you know and Brooke
supports our powering through it because
she powers through Brooke powers through
to I think I think Brooke likes to power
through certain talking points but
doesn't want to power through other
talking points because she's a hack I
mean this obviously you could you could
pull up this kind of footage and the
thing about power through I mean you had
Robby Mook the Clinton campaign chairman
pushing this line whereas an unbroken
they were talking about the mob
mentality of the left right now you had
Matt Lewis who's just a writer for The
Daily Beast he's actually the left wing
publication he's making the point that
they actually are calling for mob
violence Maxine Waters is calling for
mob violence Democrats around the
country or using mob violence and she
says you can't use that one now if you
were talking about Hillary power and
through all right maybe we can get along
with that so so they're getting sloppy
the left is getting sloppy now this has
been the case since basically since
Donald Trump announced he was running
for president certainly since November
2016 so we're also seeing this in big
tech so it's not just the politicians
it's not just the media it's also in big
technology Twitter at this point I think
has no even remotely plausible claim to
being fair to treating the left in the
right
fairly this happened within the last
couple days because of one Louis
Farrakhan Louis Farrakhan you know the
Nation of Islam certain if anybody is a
hate monger in the united states as
Louis Farrakhan he talks about the white
devil talks about the Satanic Jews he's
a race hustler you know for black people
and by the way yeah they actually took a
photo with Barack Obama in 2005 that the
mainstream media buried it they would
not let this be released during the
presidential election because Farrakhan
is such a wicked dude he's such a
hatemonger
and he's such a race hustler so
Farrakhan though still is allowed to
have his Twitter account Twitter doesn't
mind he posted a tweet that said I'm not
anti-semite I'm anti
along with this video clip
why folk don't like vodka some of them
respect me but those who have been our
deceivers they can't stand me so when
they talk about Farrakhan call me a
hater you know what they do call me an
anti-semite stop it
I'm auntie termite do you get it do you
get what he is saying
the Jews according to Louis Farrakhan
are like bugs that eat away at wood in
your house did you get it I just in case
you didn't get it because that's Louis
Farrakhan he's allowed to have his
Twitter meanwhile Alex Jones all Alex
Jones is doing is warning people that
you know the freaking frogs are turning
gay all he's trying to do is shirtless
Li sell vitamins to people he loses his
Twitter account
Gavin McGinnis who just wrestles babies
that's I think is the biggest crime in
life as it he wrestles newborn babies he
loses his Twitter account but Louis
Farrakhan who calls Jews termites he
gets to keep his Twitter account that's
how that's how it works because those
two guys are brought of Jones and Gavin
are considered broadly within the the
right-wing Jones a little less oh but
Gavin is and Louis Farrakhan is
considered within the left-wing
so they let Louis Farrakhan keep his
Twitter account what this is showing is
that nothing ever changes in politics
it's showing that big tech is now taking
over the role of the mainstream media in
censoring conservatives for decades and
decades the mainstream media not only
censored conservatives but they wouldn't
let conservatives go on their shows and
then only present them in the way that
the left wanted to present them so they
distort what they had to say they would
pervert their messages they would always
filter conservative thought through the
lens of the mainstream media a new media
and big technology allowed us to get our
message out there unadulterated that's
how you're seeing the show right now
probably and but now you know more and
more YouTube will censor those shows
will de monetize those shows Facebook
same thing
more and more Twitter will cancel the
accounts or censor the accounts or
suspend the accounts of conservative
people and not do the same on the left
they are now taking over the role of the
media in the censoring conservatives
alike I like this story in a certain
sense because it means that politics is
never over the left is always coming out
to get you and the Empire is always
striking back which you know fair enough
that means you've got to stay on your
toes there's there's nothing new Under
the Sun and it means that we have to
innovate you know part of the reason I
think that Republicans and conservatives
have had an advantage here is because
there's all this pressure to innovate to
innovate on policy conservatives have
have been leading on policy for
certainly my entire lifetime and before
that left the left has no policy ideas
that the only policy idea is to go back
to 19th century socialism that's the
left big policy idea but all of the
think tanks are conservative all of the
actual policy centers are conservative
because there is a pressure on us to
innovate same thing with new media
conservatives dominate new media why do
they dominate because there's a pressure
on us we have to do it or else we can't
get our message yet and now
conservatives are gonna have to innovate
again you know we had a good run in this
iteration of social media and we're
gonna have to keep innovating again
all of this is a little bit of a
sideshow all of this is a little bit of
what's gonna happen in November what's
gonna happen in the midterms what's
gonna very few people are talking about
what is happening right now in the
levers of government and this underlies
a totally false attack from the left and
the right on dumb Trump which is that
he's too sensationalist he's too much of
a showman I just want him to you know
sign tax laws or whatever I just want
him to tweak parts of the welfare state
okay right when he does that no one
would cover it he would have no ability
to galvanize public support on those
issues here's one example of it during a
cabinet meeting President Trump made a
pretty big announcement gave a pretty
big directive to his cabinet secretaries
which items certain you haven't seen
anywhere but it's very important here he
is
ask everybody to come back with a 5% cut
our next meeting I think you'll all be
able to do it it may be a special
exemption perhaps I don't know who that
exemption would be if you can do more
than 5 some of you will say hey I can be
much more than 5 I'm sorry was doing my
Ruth Bader Ginsburg impression while I
was watching that
that cabinet meeting because nobody's
watching this and nobody's watching it
because while it's very very important
it's not a show so people aren't going
to cover it it's Donald Trump at a
cabinet meeting saying you know we need
to do is cut these departments by 5% if
we cut them by 1 percent year over year
over year we would ever a number of
years we would have a significant
reduction certainly in the growth of the
federal government if not in the federal
government itself Trump is saying we're
going to do even more than that we're
going to reduce it 5% within this year
and I'm sure we can do it of course they
can do that nevertheless and nobody's
going to cover that because it's
actually Trump just holding a meeting
one thing this shows us is that there is
a serious Trump all we think is of cocoa
FFA and horseface Trump but there is
this serious Trump who look the guy's a
workaholic he's built a lot of
businesses he's risen to the top of very
difficult fields obviously this guy can
work within normal business environments
but he eat because he's a showman he
understands that that's how you
galvanize public support and we need the
showmanship because this would not be
covered this would not galvanize public
support this would not get a win even
though it's extraordinarily important
work and I just want to point out every
now and again that very important work
like this deregulation shrinking parts
of the federal government cutting back
on certain costs this that is happening
right now you're just not seeing it
because it's not part of the show and
probably it's good that you're not
seeing that part of it it's probably
good to have the media off your
jabbering about horseface which is
totally trivial and doesn't matter at
all because what really matters is this
and we don't want the mainstream media's
eyes on us shrinking parts of the
government hopefully shrinking more of
the government as the administration
goes on the other good thing the
president Trump has done for the office
of the presidency is that he's made it
less mystical less majestic less he's
taken less responsibility for every
little thing that happens in the entire
world President
Trump was asked to give his thoughts and
what would happen in the midterm
elections here's what he thinks if they
don't go out and vote then they have
themselves to blame because they'll lose
wealth tremendous amount I built up
eleven point seven trillion dollars and
wealth you report on it I've built up
all this wealth in the country we've
built up all the economies to it done so
so well if people don't go out there and
vote for Republicans they have nothing
nobody but themselves to blame I'd love
this answer because during the Obama
administration all you would hear is
it's me I will I will make the Seas sea
levels lower I will uh we are the ones
that we've been waiting for we are it's
me me me I me my all through the night I
me my I me my I me my you're doing is
George Harrison impression Donald Trump
actually doesn't do that for a guy who
slaps his name on every building he's
ever seen in his life he actually says
look under all I can do is what I'm
doing I'm just Donald Trump what do you
expect from me I'm Donald Trump I
deregulate I cut taxes I make the the
country friendlier to businesses I make
the government friendlier to business
but you've got to go out there and vote
I'm not gonna do that I can't do that
for you and if you don't want it alright
that's your fault that's a good attitude
because you can't just throw all of your
hopes and dreams
to quote Barack Obama onto one guy Trump
is not a god he's not a deity he's not a
messiah
he's Donald Trump he emphatically and
manifestly not any of those other things
and so we got him he's a great tool he's
a great leader he's actually a great
political leader he's a great political
executive he's not a messiah you've got
to go out and do the work of reelecting
Republicans or you're not going to keep
getting it and if you can't do it you
got nobody to blame but your self we
have a lot of mailbag to get to right
now before we do that though I have got
to say goodbye to Facebook and YouTube
look I I know that we're probably
already being censored on there anyway
some of your on daily wire.com you've
got to subscribe to daily wire right now
why one because we're going to politican
this weekend we're to be a politican in
Los Angeles on Saturday and Sunday I'm
gonna be there on some
if you're not in LA if you haven't
bought tickets if you're not going to go
you can stream it on daily wire.com but
you can only do that obviously you know
you can only interact with us if you're
a subscriber so make sure you come on
over there also because you need your
leftist ears tumblr okay I know it's ten
bucks a month hundred dollars for an
annual membership you get me the under
claiming show the bench bureau show you
get asked questions in the mailbag which
is coming up questions in the
conversation this is what you need and
if you drown in a sea of leftist tears
you've got nobody to blame but yourself
I'm channeling my inner Donald Trump
you've got nobody to blame but yourself
because this I have warned you you've
seen the tidal wave coming you've got
the vessel it's not that expensive go to
daily wire calm we'll be right back with
the mailbag
all right here we go from Carlos since
you are a Catholic I'm guessing you
don't believe in same-sex marriage do
you also believe the government has the
authority to make same-sex marriage
illegal if so what would be the
arguments for doing so it's true that
I'm a Catholic but my opinion of the
redefinition of marriage does not hinge
on my Catholic faith it's not that I
think that gay marriage should be legal
or illegal I think gay marriage is a
contradiction in terms
this is no offense to friends of mine
who are gay or who have any any sort of
sexual preference at all it's about what
marriage is and unfortunately during the
the question of gay marriage when the
Supreme Court stole it from the public
sphere we totally missed this debate the
question isn't who should have the right
to get marriage the question is what is
marriage the people who support same-sex
marriage say that sexual difference
doesn't in here in marriage well your
man or your woman it doesn't matter it
has nothing to do with marriage marriage
is just what is marriage sir well you
know it's the union of two people who
really like each other okay that could
be friends well no it's the union of two
people who really like each other and
have sex with each other that could also
be friends you know
welcome to 2018 well no it's the Union
for well for this or that
they can't quite give an explanation for
all of human history sexual difference
has been the essence of marriage a union
of husbands and wives at least one
husband usually just one life sometimes
more than one wife depending on your
culture in the West basically it's for a
very long time it's been one man and one
husband and one wife because those two
complement one another in the beginning
God created man both male and female he
created them in our culture in the
Western culture they the husband and the
wife leave their families cleave
together for what purpose well there's
the logical possibility of life of
procreation of creating a family if the
family being the essential building
block of society the the question that
you have to ask yourself if you support
redefining marriage
to encode there are a few questions you
have to ask yourself if you support
redefining marriage to include
monogamous same-sex unions if you say
sexual difference doesn't matter is why
not include polygamous same-sex unions
why that's not I'm not being I'm not
trying to be offensive in any way why
wouldn't you if it's just about the
union of people who love each other
III know polygamists and polyamorous
people why I've been you know I've I
wouldn't call them close friends but
they're acquaintances at least why
wouldn't that constitute marriage well
if sexual difference doesn't in here in
marriage them then then what does
marriage become what is it really about
I've never heard a good answer to this
why should why should the Supreme Court
decide that I don't know marriage has a
definition and the Supreme Court can't
change that and I don't think public
debate even can change that though I'd
prefer if public debate did over the
Supreme Court marriage has a definition
in there for gay marriage is a logical
impossibility does it mean that gay
people can't live together or do
whatever they want or sign contract no
of course not go with God man I'm not
here to tell you how to live your life
but but it means that you can't change
the word you can't change logic if we
don't have if we can't agree on
definitions we can't live together in a
society we can't communicate so that's
that's my position on that I guess now
this is an unpopular position even
though virtually everybody in the entire
West held it until just a few years ago
I think that our current
misunderstanding of the definition of
words is a is a momentary madness I
think at some point we'll wake up from
that but right now people are very
confused and which is why you've got
activists in the street shrieking and
howling it's because they're very
confused and they can't articulate their
points of view from Joseph dear Michael
the world has ended civilization as we
know it has collapsed and been reset you
are one of the few who have survived
this disaster so what three items
besides the Bible would you take with
you into this new world why thanks and
by the way I don't think you are
execrable well you know I probably a
purple mattress movement watch in a week
of blue apron that's what I take into
the world promo code Kofi
baby beyond that if I had to choose
another three I would choose this is
very hard these questions are always
impossible but to reconstruct
civilization I would probably choose I
would bring Dante the Divine Comedy
annotated Divine Comedy because the
Divine Comedy includes basically all of
Western culture is referred to in it or
alluded to or brought in together
Western Christian theology and
philosophy and ancient philosophy and
literature and it's the greatest work of
art in the West so I'd take that I would
take Shakespeare specifically Hamlet
because Hamlet is talking about the
crack-up of Western civilization
probably the thing that sowed the seeds
for what led to that apocalypse that I'm
now trying to recover from and and all
the works of Shakespeare and probably
Aristotle so I would take literature I
would take really extraordinary
literature and theology literature and
philosophy I wish that we could get a
little history in there too but you said
I could only take three things from
Spenser Oh Knowles who knows in your
opinion how can we best discover God's
will for our lives
how can we distinguish God's will from
what merely happens to us more
specifically how can we know whether or
not we've acted in accordance with God's
will when we make crucial decisions such
as where to go to school whom to marry
where to work etc Spenser it is a wicked
generation that looks for signs and
wonders as as the Bible tells us but it
is a stupid generation that ignores
signs and wonders so so you shouldn't
you know be trying to interpret tea
leaves when you're trying to figure out
if you should go to this college or
marry this person or whatever however we
I think with all many of us have had
numinous experience the experience of
coincidence or Providence or whatever
that really makes you think huh all
right this has the unmistakable mark of
God on it when these things happen they
don't always give you a right answer I
can't often these experiences these
religious experiences are ineffable so
they're really hard to relate in words
what they are but you know it's like
pornography
you can't define it but you know when
you say it I mean that's the only way
it's like pornography so what I would
say when I've had these experiences when
friends of mine have had these
experiences while we're trying to make
certain decisions what I oh I don't
interpret them to mean one course of
action or the other or this or that I
always take them to mean that God is
there and that you know maybe you're on
the right track maybe you're where
you're supposed to be because you're
seeing you're seeing a sign or a wonder
for all the rest of it you should use
your reason you should use your desire
and your will and your intellect and
pursue the virtues you know I mean it's
it's on you man it's your life you've
got to lead your life and fortunately
there is the grace of God that abounds
and that will help you out and lead you
in the right way and there's the helper
and the Advocate but it requires a your
own will and as well so it's not you
can't look to signs and wonders to be an
excuse not to use your own faculties of
reason in your own determination and
courage and will and all the other
virtues you got to do that but in a way
don't worry about it so much because God
is there but you've got to put in the
effort and you you've got to put in the
work and you know just remember in the
long run as long as you're doing the
right thing you can't go wrong from an
hi Michael just found out the the
leftists are using the Lord's name in
vain they always do that
claiming Jesus is a Palestinian please
explain this rhetoric and oh it's
because they're very dumb I think that's
why they're they're going Jesus of
Palestine for a while they were saying
Jesus is black or Jesus is it's always
just in to be used in political debates
so when there was a political debate in
the United States over black and white
race relations they would they would do
that now there's a big political debate
over Israelis and their treatment of
Palestinian Arabs and so were they're
saying Jesus was a Palestinian he wasn't
he isn't he isn't a Palestinian Christ
is a Jew he's he he partook of Jewish
customs he did Jewish things he taught
in the temple he died died for your sins
and was resurrected
on the third day and but he's not a
Palestinian what the point that they're
trying to make is always this cheap
political plan to say Jesus is a
socialist and you say well why do you
think that because I saw a meme about it
on Reddit one time say okay can you
explain can you give any example of
Jesus being a socialist and they never
can so I think the people who are saying
Jesus is a Palestinian look just to use
the phrase Jesus was is if you do that
enough times you're kind of showing your
cards because the for those of us who
believe in Jesus Jesus is before Abraham
was he is but but also they just haven't
read the Bible you know it's all the
people who tend to preach the most about
these things politically did tend to
have never cracked the spine of a Bible
so I would just laugh at them they're
gonna come up with some new one when
there's a new political issue as well hi
Michael do you believe in the deep state
and if so what do you think about it and
how do you think it's affecting our
government and democracy from Caleb okay
he didn't put his name up down yeah by
definition the deep state exists cuz the
deep state is the entrenched federal
bureaucracy that is unaccountable to
voters and that can't be moved along by
elections so that does exist I don't
think it's like men twirling their
moustaches in a bunker for the most part
there are those types I mean there are
those guys you know like some some of
the FBI guys Peter struck you know
actually when he was testifying before
Congress he did look like a villain from
a James Bond movie but most of them are
just bureaucrats who who are so
entrenched in the government is so
bloated and big and powerful and
unaccountable that elections don't
matter because the elected officials
come and go but those bureaucrats live
forever you know bureaucrats have come
closest to finding the Philosopher's
Stone and immortality on earth as
virtually impossible to fire them James
o keeffe's videos quoted a bunch of DOJ
officials saying that we can't lose our
jobs so that does exist in the way to
fight that is to shrink the size of the
federal bureaucracy the Trump
administration has done a beautiful job
at that before they finally claimed
scott pruett before they finally threw
him out of office he was doing an
excellent job cutting the size of the
EPA and hopefully we'll be able to
continue that because bureaucracies are
natural
going to do this I don't even ascribe
ascribe ill intention to a lot of these
people it just naturally happens and the
only way to stop that is to shrink it
keep it small and keep the government
accountable from aslam Michael I've
found debating points with the left is
becoming far more taxing because they're
so entrenched how do you pick and choose
your battles especially with people you
respect as a friend esslyn well Kanye
West is a good example of this Kanye
West you know he came out he he gave his
political opinion which all of his
friends disagree with and they they
tried to guilt him they tried to shame
him they say your fans don't want this
you're you're ill I'm worried about you
but the racism you said you can throw
out all the slogans you wants not gonna
change my mind I would say two things
I'm friends with a lot of Democrats you
know I've lived in New York and LA and
went to a very left-wing school if I
were not friends with Democrats I
wouldn't have that many friends one
thing I always try to do with them is I
never back down I never try to play nice
and conciliatory and don't rock the boat
I am I will exaggerate my political
views if anything with some of them
because you don't want them to bully you
into going along and agreeing with that
if they're not gonna like you because of
your political point of view you don't
want to be friends with them anyway that
said though I don't poke them I don't
prod them I don't talk about politics
all the time if they bring something up
I'll double down they say oh you know
Trump Trump called stormy Daniels
horseface say I know it was so rude to
mr. ed to compare her to to miss it to
horses you know is so rude to all those
horses and then maybe they can back off
it or something always you know double
down don't let anything go unanswered
but you don't need to poke them all the
time because why are you friends with
them you're presumably friends with them
because you share some points of view
you share some values you share some
activities together you like them and so
you don't want a problem you don't
dislike them but never back down never
back down no the real way is don't pick
any battles to begin with if a battle is
picked with you though you fight it
right back from Augusta or Augustine
Mike my very liberal economics teacher
says the Trump tax cuts are awesome in
the short run but not great in the long
run due to problems and the large debt
that large debt can cause down the
and the tax cuts do not really help that
issue how do I respond to this MDG oh
well first of all to quote famous
liberal economist John Maynard Keynes in
the long run we're all dead no they're
great in the short run and they're great
in the long run and the dead is a
problem all of those things can be true
your teacher is right that the debt is a
major problem not a problem from merrily
caused by the Republicans by the way the
the debt and deficit under Barack Obama
expanded dramatically you had regular
trillion dollar deficits and and
President Trump has not tackled that
problem yet the main response I would
say is that tax cuts don't cause the
debt entitlements cause the debt
entitlements are the majority of the
federal budget they cause the debt they
are the main driver of the debt they are
insolvent they will make the debt worse
and the deficits worse if they are not
checked it is Democrats who are not
allowing us to address those entitlement
programs Medicare Medicaid Social
Security which will bankrupt the country
and won't be there for the young workers
who are paying into it right now tax
cuts don't do that tax cuts let people
keep a little bit more of their own
money that's fine that's perfectly fine
and they can stimulate economic growth
if people are serious about taking on
the debt you're not gonna do it by
raising taxes because that also could
damage the economy you're not gonna do
it with pork barrel spending that's
another favorite buzzword of the left
and the right you're not gonna do it by
eliminating some bridge projects
somewhere or whatever you're going to do
it by tackling the lion's share of our
budget and the main driver of debt and
that's entitlement programs show me
someone who has the guts to deal with
entitlement programs other than Paul
Ryan who is at now has had his career
basically finished in the Congress show
me someone with that courage and I'll
vote for that person but I don't I don't
see it anytime soon time for one more
all right time for one more from L on
should we believe all men if gender
equality is our goal
Thanks what a great question to end on
you know just wow we should believe all
women and because women are equal to men
we should believe all men and therefore
we shouldn't believe all women
and we shouldn't believe all men we
should believe credible people and give
the accused the presumption of innocence
until they're proven guilty wow man that
is some poetry I'm gonna have to tweet
that out okay that's our show we're
gonna be back tomorrow for a Friday show
because I ditched you on Tuesday to go
give a speech so tune in tomorrow in the
meantime I'm Michael Knowles this is the
Michael Nolt show I'll see you tomorrow
[Music]
the Michael Nolt show is produced by
seniya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stevens edited by Jim nickel
audio is mixed by mic core Amina hair
and makeup is by Jessa alvera the
Michael Noel's show is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright for
word publishing 2018